ما هي المدة التي ستستغرقها تلك
القوات الروسية
لأني أود أن أكرر أن أه
11 تلالًا
تعرضت للهجوم في وقت واحد ، حيث
كانت المباني الحكومية
تحرق السجون وتم مهاجمة الدوائر
وتم منع
عمل المسعفين الأوائل والعاملين الطبيين
ورجال الإطفاء و
كانوا يهددون السكان
بنهب الممتلكات
وكل هذه الأشياء
خلقت مشكلة كبيرة
لسلطات إنفاذ القانون في كازاخستان ،
لذا فإن الرئيس الذي يستخدم حقه
في الدفاع عن النفس
عن البلاد
قدم طلبًا لوحدة صغيرة
من
جنود حفظ سلام معاهدة الأمن الجماعي
للحضور إلى كازاخستان ولحماية
المواقع الإستراتيجية بشكل رئيسي في الجزء الجنوبي
من بلدنا والتي سمحت لقوات
إنفاذ القانون لدينا بالتركيز على
عملية مكافحة الإرهاب
وأه محاربة الجناة
الذين كانوا يهاجمون
أه مدن بلدي
ردًا على ثانيكم  استجوب هذا
أه صغير أه فرق حفظ السلام
نبقى هنا أه لفترة وجيزة جدا
حتى حل أه كامل
أو استقرار الوضع
في البلاد